Ці жінки працювали медсестрами в Україні - поки війна не змусила їх утікати за кордон.
Зараз у Німеччині вони хочуть і далі працювати за своїм фахом.
Але для цього їм потрібна додаткова підготовка.
Вони отримують її в лікарні Вайльгайм у Баварії.
Це Інна Ткаченко з Харкова. Їй 34 і вона має три роки досвіду у професії.
Анна Гарник приїхала зі Львова. Зі своїх 44 років вона 25 років працювала медсестрою.
Катерина Баландюх - теж зі Львова, вона працювала медсестрою чотири роки.
Катерина Баландюх приїхала в Німеччину місяць тому.
В Україні вона залишила родину, друзів, роботу.
Катерина працювала помічницею стоматолога, тож робота медсестри для неї незвична. Але їй допомагають.
А зараз скануємо… Одягай рукавички.
Віта Чорна теж з України, але вона в Німеччині вже два роки.
Дівчина навчає нову колегу найнеобхіднішому.
Робота подобається. Я стараюся покращувати свої навички і, звісно, вивчати мову, тому що без мови важко.
Тіло Рудлофф відповідає за організацію роботи відділу з догляду пацієнтів.
Він дивується, наскільки швидко нові співробітниці адаптувалися до роботи в Німеччині.
Хоча є ще кілька речей, яких їм треба навчитися.
Вони вже компетентні. Просто обов’язки медсестри в Німеччині відрізняються від тих, що є в Україні чи Сербії.
У Німеччині більше уваги приділяється базовому догляду - особиста гігієна, харчування, контроль прийому ліків - ніж за кордоном, в Україні.
Там медсестри не миють пацієнтів. Там йдеться про суто медичне обслуговування.
І в плані медичної допомоги українські медсестри насправді більш компетентні, ніж німецькі колеги.
Найбільша проблема - це не обов’язки медсестри, а німецька мова.
Адже нові співробітниці лікарні повинні знати медичну термінологію і вміти читати інформацію про ліки та спосіб їх введення.
Тож українки по дві години щодня інтенсивно вивчають німецьку.
Хоча найбільше, зізнаються, вчаться у колег-медиків.
Найбільшим викликом для нас є інтеграція українських медсестер у команду.
Наші співробітники завжди беруть із собою нових колег.
Вони не можуть просто займатися своїми повсякденними справами, а мають ще й перекладати.
І робити це постійно щодня.
Віта Чорна точно знає, як почуваються новачки.
Їй теж довелося починати практично з нуля.
Тепер, через два роки після приїзду в Німеччину, вона стала повністю акредитованою медичною сестрою.
І залюбки навчає своїх нових колег.
Я допомагаю від щирого серця, з усією душею, тому що це - мої співвітчизниці. Я маю їм допомагати.
Нові співробітниці регулярно зустрічаються з відповідальною за інтеграцію в лікарні.
Вона консультує із запитань, які виникають у українок, допомагає, наприклад,
під час оформлення документів чи відвідування державних установ.
Це важлива робота, тому що третина сестринського персоналу приїжджає з-за кордону!
До того ж багато хто з тих, хто виїхав з України, розмірковують над тим, аби назавжди оселитися в Німеччині.
Ми сподіваємося, що наша родина зможе жити там, де нам буде спокійно.
Тож поки що зарано говорити про те, що щось закінчиться, кудись рухатися…
Нам подобається в Німеччині, тому ми не виключаємо можливості, що залишимося тут.
Добрий день! Я медсестра… і я би хотіла виміряти ваш тиск.
Попереду в Інни Ткаченко ще рік навчання, потім іспит.
Лише після цього українка стане акредитованою медсестрою в Німеччині.